bonjour donc je suis antoine treuille le
propriétaire du priory d'or jez alors
derrière moi il ya un jardin botanique
qui a été une collection botanique qui a
été créée essentiellement par mon père
donc avant l'achat de la propriété en
1966 le 7è deschamps tout simplement
aidé à vue un vieux vignoble
tout a été nettoyé arraché est planté
donc tout ce que vous voyez ici sauf le
grand cèdre qui date de la révolution
française
en fait à 50 ans l'idée de mon père
était à la fois de créer une collection
botanique pas que c'était un grand
collectionneur et en même temps de créer
un jardin d'agrément un jardin d'un peu
havre de paix mon père a beaucoup voyagé
en orient aimait beaucoup la chine et
japon et donc il s'est inspiré aussi de
japonais de jardin japonais de et de
sites orientaux pour créer ce jardin et
en définir les taxes pectives et puis à
ranger les plans d'ensemble
le parc est connu pour sa collection de
pivoines il ici environ 240 espèces de
pivoine différente des pivoines
arbustives déployèrent bas c est ce qu
on appelle des hybrides
ito ses pivoines sont assez remarquables
fleuries sont en général en début mai et
donc on crée une grande fête des
pivoines au début mais qui est très très
visité alors après les pivoines vienne
typiquement les roses et les iris
maintenant nous arrivons en juin vont
fleurir les hémérocalles est une assez
jolie collection d'hémérocalles
et les hortensias moi je m'intéressais
absolument pas la botanique par contre
j'aime beaucoup jardiner j'aime beaucoup
entretenir les plantes désherber tondre
la pelouse lui ce que lui n'aimait pas
faire mais par la force des choses
j'ai appris à nommer les plantes et je
connais maintenant assez bien tout les
plans du parc il y en a deux mille
quatre cents et aussi je me suis
astreint à fabriquer des petites
étiquettes avec les codes qr qui
permettent aux visiteurs de savoir ce
qu'ils voient et d'apprendre en même
temps